the taliban has declared it wants
peaceful relations with other countries
in its first news conference since
taking control in afghanistan the group
has been keen to show a new face to the
world pledging inclusion and education
for women and religious tolerance the
group insists it will offer amnesty to
anyone who works with the government or
foreign forces but reports of taliban
rule in cities captured during the
group's advance have raised fears about
these promises
we have pardoned anyone all those who
had fought against us we don't want a
repeat of war we want to do away with
the factors of conflict so the islamic
emirate of afghanistan does not have any
conflict with anybody we want the
fighting to end
the islamic emirate of afghanistan is
committed to the rights of women within
the framework of sharia our women have
the same rights they can work in
different sectors on the basis of our
rules and regulations in education and
health and other areas
they are going to be working shoulder to
shoulder with us we want to assure the
international community there will be no
discrimination against women but of
course within our religious framework
well let's go live now to kabul where we
can speak with our correspondent rob
mcbride rob you were watching that news
conference from start to finish
how would you
summarize it
think it was as we expected you know
we've seen uh it's not quite a charm
offensive but yeah you know after uh all
of the the military offensive of the
recent weeks it is certainly uh the the
the taliban trying to reassure the
international community and also with
afghans themselves that this is going to
be a different type of regime a
different type of government a softer
side if you like more respectful and
inclusive all of these key words we've
tended to hear in the last week or two
or two and now we hear it in this first
official news conference it is very
important this is almost like the
keynote address i guess for this new
government it's been long anticipated it
was meant to take place so we heard uh
talk that it could have taken place
yesterday monday uh it got delayed and
now we have it so this is important
interestingly right at the end there we
have heard that uh this will become it
seems a regular feature there will be
news conferences uh on a regular basis
moving forward rather like uh the the
kind of international community the
western liberal sort of uh countries
that it seems this news conference was
aimed at you did get the sense that uh
although they were
we were addressing issues that are very
important here in afghanistan and to all
the afghan journalists who were there in
this news conference it was very mindful
of what the world watching would think
about this new government and
the taliban comes into power here really
with something of a hill to climb you
have a very skeptical international
audience looking at this organization
given all of the history that we know
about going back 20 years it has
unexpectedly in many respects suddenly
found itself inheriting this country and
there is an extreme skepticism from the
international community about the way
the taliban conducted itself for example
during these negotiations that as part
of the agreement as part of the process
it was meant to enter into negotiations
with the uh what is now the the defunct
government uh
that has just just been just collapsed
but it was was meant to negotiate with
that government and there is skepticism
that it was playing for time that it
was acting in bad faith all of those
things obviously which the taliban
denies and it blames the other side it
blames the outgoing government uh for
acting in bad faith and for
bringing about the crisis that that
resulted in its downcoming so all of
this did seem to be aimed at trying to
convince the overseas audience and
you've got a lot of that they did
address some of those issues
particularly that uh
the international community is concerned
about one thing we didn't mention
earlier was that the fact that never
again would afghanistan be would allow
afghanistan land or soil to be used for
the training of groups of fighters who
would threaten those countries overseas
that was one of the big concerns that
obviously led to all of that led to the
intervention of 20 years ago so with
that there was that guarantee then
specifically there was the guarantee and
answer to one of the questions to the
people who are just a kilometer or two
away from here clamoring to get into the
international airport and as we were
listening to the news conference we hear
occasionally uh gunshots ring out
sometimes the old single shot sometimes
automatic gunfire as uh taliban uh
guards and fighters who have a cordon
around the terminal try to keep our
people back it is a reminder it gives
you the context of what's happening here
but there was the assurance for all of
those people that there is no need to
run that there is a guarantee that there
will not be reprisals or grudges or a
knock on the door or interrogations as
they put it the people who are there can
go home there
there will not be any recriminations it
remains to be seen whether the people
who are in fear uh this tuesday evening
that they are going to be targeted
whether they will believe that or not
but certainly that was the message that
the taliban wanted to get across with
this news conference okay rob mcbride
there reporting live for us from
cardboard rob thank you the head of the
taliban's political office in qatar's
capital doha is heading back to
afghanistan mullah abdul hani baradar
led the group's negotiations in peace
talks with the u.s and afghan
governments he departed after meeting
qatar's foreign minister earlier today
talks between the taliban and former
afghan officials will now be held
domestically instead of in doha
let's bring in harun rahimi he's the
assistant an assistant professor of law
at the american university of
afghanistan and joins us by skype from
istanbul it's good to have you with us
again
it's quite significant is it not that
mul abdullah ghani
is heading back to afghanistan
does this give any indication do you
think of
who's going to be making up the
government's
what kind of government we're going to
see especially now that the the top
people are basing themselves in the
capital of the country uh they have just
seized
so let's just be clear that he's not the
top person in the taliban movement
he's been the head of the political
office in
doha but they have a system of
leadership where the leadership council
is at the head and mulla brother has
generally been acting as the face the
political office he can compare him to
kind of administer foreign affairs in a
sense but the head of the military camp
committee and the head of the leadership
committee are two different people um in
terms of what kind of government we can
expect now given the developments we've
observed so far
i had hoped and the hope had been that
there will be an interim government that
is neutral um that hope was lost when
kenny escaped kabul and taliban said
that they had to step in to uh fail the
vacuum they could not just wait until
the interim government uh
and they could not wait for an interim
government to take over from kanye and
then a new government will be formed
under the supervision of an interim
government that is not the case now
taliban are for all internet purposes in
charge and they will be controlling the
process through which a new government
will be formed this means that we will
be having a taliban control process
through which an inclusive government
will be formed
taliban are pretty much holding all
cards there are two considerations that
may
kind of point towards a more inclusive
system
one is international intimacy it is
something that is very that is important
to taliban it's one of the things they
care about they they care about many
things that some often may come in
tension with their
desire to have international intimacy
we'll have to see how trade-offs will
work out um the second issue the
consideration that may point towards
possible more inclusive government even
despite the fact that taliban will
control the process of creating the
government
is their desire to have domestic
legitimacy you have to realize that the
taliban are not a popular movement they
are becoming more popular i believe they
are
given that they are in maintaining law
and order and they are saying some of
the right things but there's still a
large part of the population is
incredibly uh skeptical of them
distrusting fears proprietal and
remembers the context through which they
conduct a brutal war killed civilians
and conducting many many many sort of
crimes
and against the population so you have a
very unconvinced population and
they will if they are have foresight
they will care to have uh the
different constitutions of afghanistan
uh
represented in the government to gain
domestic legitimacy if they fail to do
that to fail to do uh form an inclusive
garment that would ensure international
domestic legitimacy then i'm afraid that
we will have a resistance formed forming
against them the same way when in born
one taliban were executed when the uh
2001 the new system was formed after the
problem were
toppled we saw the taliban insurgency
kind of re-emerging uh tell about
emerging as an insurgency now there are
pence that there will be an insurgency
formed i mean the former vp claimed that
he's uh he's the head of is still the
caretaker of the government and there
are hence i mean pansher still is not
has not surrendered to the taliban and
some military reporter there are rumors
that some military ads were moved there
so i mean and those are
still on hold and it's going to depend
on whether the rabon will be able to
bring in their opposition into the
government to neutralize any
preempt any possibility of resistance
becoming popular even i mean some people
may still call it resistance but how
inclusive their government will be is
going to determine uh how popular the
resistance will be and international
intimacy is also important because uh
it's going to determine who's willing to
possibly uh help resistance or or not
okay uh very notable there lots of focus
in that pressure on
trying to get people to stay in the
country to prevent a brain drain to
rebuild the nation we'll just have to
wait and see if the the people of
afghanistan will heed that call for now
harun rahimi uh great to get your
analysis and your thoughts thank you
very much
in deeds now the nato secretary general
has called on the taliban to facilitate
the departure of all those who want to
leave the country jan stoltenberg also
blamed the afghan forces for what's
happening in kabul right now
the afghan political leadership failed
to stand up to the taliban and to
achieve the peaceful solution that
afghans desperately wanted
this failure of afghan leadership led to
the tragedy we are witnessing today
turkey and greece fear being at the
forefront of another refugee crisis as
thousands of afghans look to flee
taliban rule turkey's already building a
wall along its border with iran to stop
people crossing illegally
greece has said it cannot become a
gateway into the eu for afghans greece
was on the front line of europe's
migration crisis in 2015 where nearly a
million people think conflict in syria
iraq and afghanistan landed on its
islands
the eu is calling for europe to create
humanitarian corridors for afghan
refugees joanna hull reports from london
for the moment of course the focus is on
getting foreign nationals out of
afghanistan along with afghan support
staff some countries in europe are going
further the germans are adding
human rights activists lawyers other
people deemed to be at risk from the
taliban to their list of evacuees the
british government is later
due to announce details of an emergency
resettlement scheme for those most
in need focused its thought on women and
girls in afghanistan but not all
countries are going to be quite so
willing and eager to help the greeks
have already said this morning they are
not willing again to be a gateway
country for refugees
making their way from turkey across the
water water and into europe austria for
instance as we speak is still continuing
with deportation plans for failed afghan
asylum seekers back to afghanistan as a
means of deterrence for new arrivals and
doing so with the support of 90 percent
of the austrian public so it's all very
well for people like the french
president emmanuel macron to stand up as
he did on monday and call for a joined
up european approach to ensure the safe
passage of people coming if they want to
come but this is an incredibly thorny
issue in europe it's led to the downfall
of governments in recent years it
spawned right-wing movements in almost
every country governments i think will
certainly be on their guard if not all
of them actively preparing to
accommodate what may soon be coming
their way
there are huge parts of afghanistan
where the taliban enjoy supports from
certain ethnic groups the turkey border
crossing with pakistan is one such place
it has now reopened and there's no rush
of people trying to flee as kamal haider
explains
the main border crossing between
afghanistan and pakistan at torkham is
now open for business trucks have been
traveling in both directions there were
apprehensions that as the taliban
advance across the country tens of
thousands of refugees will pour across
this border into pakistan but the ground
reality is very different people living
close to the pakistani border all the
way from hillman province to nuristan up
in the north are mostly pushtoon tribes
they of course welcome the taliban they
have seen the taliban rule in the past
and what we saw at this border crossing
that instead of tens of thousands of
afghans coming across the border we saw
hundreds of afghans eager to cross that
border and go back to their country most
of the people that we spoke to over here
are elated and jubilant with the fact
that the taliban are back in power they
on the other hand do not agree with the
international community and they see a
ray of hope for a lasting afghan
settlement
we welcome the taliban back in
afghanistan as they are the true heroes
of the country and none other than them
can bring a lasting peace to this
war-torn country destroyed by many
afghanistan is in ruins from the last 40
years firstly we were made homeless by
russians and then the americans but
thank god finally we've got freedom from
their invasions we trust the taliban and
hope they will bring peace stability and
progress to this country
but while the situation on the borders
was now returning back to normal there
were frantic diplomatic efforts to try
to put the afghan leaders on the same
table with the taliban the former
foreign minister of afghanistan saladin
rabbani is in pakistan along with yunus
kanuni the head of the afghan parliament
and also ustad mohawk
is amongst that group he represents the
minority hazara community what pakistan
has been telling the afghan taliban is
that this could be an inclusive
government which would include all the
ethnic groups of afghanistan
therefore it offers a ray of hope for
the first time in two decades for a
lasting peaceful settlement to the
afghan conflict what the pakistanis have
been saying to the taliban is that it
has to be an inclusive government the
taliban have also announced an amnesty
and said that there will be no
retribution even for those people who've
been working with the americans
well girls in the western afghan city of
herats have attended school just days
after the taliban takeover the armed
group says it will ensure inclusiveness
for women despite its strict guidelines
on how they should dress the united
nations is urging the taliban to keep
its promises